hello rejects Gregory Angelo Alba senior
here and I'm John continuing our Edition
a weekend of horror we thought we review
one of the few horror films that's
actually coming out in October yeah 31
Rob Zombie's 31 we saw this one a while
ago a special Fandango event where I
almost got into a fight with a drunk guy
because he thought I was looking at this
overweight woman yeah maybe it was my
intake a little jab there why did you
have a her that's Jeff him yeah okay
yeah drunk he had like a mustache yeah
bowler hat it was a basic plot let's
read from hi Andy be here cuz they have
the most basic way of forming in five
carnival workers 5 not 31 31 garner are
kidnapped and held hostage in an
abandoned Hell like compound where they
are forced to participate in a violent
game the goal of which is to survive 12
hours against a gang of sadistic clowns
written and directed by Robert zombies
this film was quite an experience I feel
like you'd appreciate this film if you
are already a fan of a prior Rob Zombie
you films I don't want to say it's not
creative it's definitely more in tune
with what we kind of expect from Rob
Zombie any actually he himself and I I
had that thought during the movie I was
like this this seems like Rob Zombie
took kind of everything he's he's done
with his movies and kind of rolled them
like this movie is the Rob Zombie estuve
Rob Zombie yeah I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing but it is like
lean in that sense like it's a simple
setup so and here we go you know we're
gonna watch some people try to survive
against a host of really insane villains
and can they do it maybe that's like
what a eighty ninety minute film in the
film though the best part was the
opening scene that is the best piece is
the actor Richard break the best parts I
think of this movie to me are sort of
the bookends and especially the opening
really any scene with that character
doom head like that's when the
filmmaking in and of itself is at its
best and when the writing is at its best
because the thing about Rob Zombie
people complain all the time he always
writes these you know podunk hillbilly
characters he's like angry he is either
provoked yeah and the thing about
Richard break is like he is a terrifying
crazy villain and I know Rob Zombie like
very much believes in creating memorable
villains and he's great at that he gives
him a sort of eloquent monologue and it
shows you at least his writing range for
characters which is nice it's a little
strange in this movie because this movie
doesn't really play to range so much as
it plays to all the things we know Rob's
on behalf of that but Richard break and
doom head do bring you know a bit of
range I mean what I would say about
range with this film is the backstory
and the development of the character
shows his range I think where Rob Zombie
kind of lacks is his writing of dialogue
cuz this dialogue in his films they all
kind of sound the same everyone kind of
talks similarly yeah for the most part I
mean you got your five main carnival
protagonists in this movie even know if
it's necessarily the dialogues all the
same it's like everybody has a similar
attitude that kind of informs how they
talk to each other there's similar kinds
of care there's a style to the dialogue
at the same time though it is like I've
seen these characters and like a lot of
other Rob Zombie yeah I've seen him
right zena's angry loud southern people
who are kind of sexual a little
perverted yeah I think Rob Simon can
definitely read a good monologue and I
don't think his dialogue is bad but I
can definitely see how you can easily
get tired of that kind of thing from him
I feel like when he deals and you know
sadistic nests when he deals with terror
my deals of evil like like the writing
of Richard breaks dialogue was really
good it's the dialogue when they're not
that that kind of annoys me for the most
part I'm a fan of Rob Zombie's films I'm
not a Rob Zombie hater by any means I
like house of 1000 corpses I love the
Devil's Rejects that's inspired the time
of this channel I'm one of the few would
proudly say I enjoy the Halloween movies
even though I have my problems with em
III for the most part I don't dislike
the Halloween remakes you did well did
you see Lourdes I did not see Lourdes
assume I heard that was his most like
does his most different one out of
he's definitely the most interesting
movie and that's that is kind of a
bummer about this is like if you want to
see Rob Zombie keep pushing cuz the
Lords of Salem was definitely an
assuring forward in style that's not
really as much what this is yeah in the
film I mean what what I do admire about
it is Rob Zombie's still is one of the
few filmmakers I know that is not afraid
to hold back in terms of the crazy
thoughts I kind of go on in his head
yeah you know in the similar sense of
how Eminem rights rap songs of the crazy
thoughts he puts in like rap poetic form
I feel like Rob Zombie does the same
thing here with characters you could
tell you know just from hearing
interviews with him and whatnot or
listening to his music but this guy kind
of has a loud head yes loud he's got
loud violent images and there's there's
a lot of pastiche in there like you know
he's taken in so much of these you know
the pulpit exploitation and monster
movies over time he seems like an
encyclopedia of this stuff and he seems
like there's an inherent enthusiasm and
he doesn't he doesn't aim for
likeability which is something that you
can kind of appreciate because you know
a lot of the key things we say movies
have likability with these characters
that yeah and I feel like he kind of
just writes what he feels is authentic
arguably what we consider authentic he
writes what he feels is authentic he
writes what he thinks and feels it's
kind of weird because it doesn't seem
like he spends a lot of thought but
that's not in a bad way it's more like
I'm just going with what I feel and I'm
putting it down on paper yeah that's
that really translates in the film he
definitely doesn't overcook his movie
yeah because these kids cuz they make
the protagonist characters they're not
exactly what you call lovable people but
they're likable enough to the point
where what's cool is that you don't
spend he doesn't spend a long time
beating around the bush waiting for the
terror to ensue for these protagonists
but he does allow you to spend some time
with them and I think that is part of
what makes the difference is like his
70s influence does help his movies I
think toad's even if the characters
aren't necessarily likable and that
might not be something you can get past
you still spend enough time with them
that you can kind of at least get on
their rhythm so that when they are
kidnapped you know you're at least kind
of with them on this journey enough to
feel the the urgency of this
like he earns his are ratings this film
is mean it is nasty it is grisly the
killers in the in the game that they're
put up against their killer clowns and
such I mean you got this one like
Mexican [ __ ] yeah then you have these
like brother clowns who are just like
nastiest [ __ ] yeah and then you've got
the the big like creepy brother and
sister yeah and then you got the elegant
people who are leading it like the
Malcom McDowel who's the Cleary affluent
you know powdered wig yeah I know trio
that's running this whole operation and
Sheri moon zombie I feel like she gets
better / zombie movie yeah anything else
I have her husband's work I don't think
but I think she gets because I remember
like early on I thought she was not kind
of an annoying actress but in this film
I was I wasn't annoyed by her I actually
I bought her and in the film though
whenever the protagonists get a chance
to kind of like fight back or you know
kind of wins what the chances when they
they get to win yeah you know I'm not
saying if they win in the end but the
moments when they get to win it is kind
of relieving in the sense of like all
right cool I'm glad you got it I'm happy
for you you gotta overcome this part
well in this movie has an interesting
balance of how the game unfolds and and
I gotta give it to him like it's it's
all very immediate it's all very linear
it's just you're trapped in this
situation for as long as it's going on
without giving too much away just the
interplay between the heroes and the
villains was not always what you'd
expect you couldn't just predict who was
gonna die when and how and which of
these villains is gonna win and which
one they're gonna overcome like I
thought they unfolded the actual game
pretty well in terms of just you know
keeping you guessing and keeping you
with the characters and I think there
are some really great performances in
this movie even if you're not into these
characters you know the thicker breaks
performances is amazing I think it was
your break isn't fantastic using this
film he's fit yeah he's amazing in this
and even people I know who hate this
movie have that have come out and been
like doom head is a spectacular
character ya know and he's terrifying
he's a horrifying villain as terrible
and challenging as that character is to
watch you can't stop watching him
because he's so in it cuz you don't
quite get like what his limit is you
don't quite get
butthis does he even have a code
necessarily yeah but at times it seems
like especially towards the end like
maybe has a code like about the game or
something yeah but then like the way
like unfolds and stuff here even have a
code really kind of unhinged well in
this movie plays it kind of smart
because it keeps it mostly in one
location and it has some pretty
interesting setups like Rob Zombie does
have a knack for interesting sets and
interesting visuals he's a guy who
especially over time as he's progressed
at least for me he can make dirty
cinematography look really compelling
that's what I mean it's like there's
there this movie does not succumb to
like ability and it is mean it is nasty
and yet there's that's what makes his
films kind of appealing cuz cuz it's
he's good at the nastiness and and
that's the thing that that I I get why
people don't like Rob Zombie movies
sometimes but it is something that I do
like about his films is that only Rob
Zombie could have offered the authored
these films even if they do borrow a lot
from past influences and stuff you know
people complain about that but we live
in the age of nostalgia yeah and this is
a nostalgia that is very specific it's
not what you get all the time this is a
through-and-through exploitation film
totally for the modern like this is a
movie you see now and you're like they
don't make stuff like this it's ugly but
sometimes for me again I like a little
bit of ugly exploitation art I like to
go there sometimes just to check it out
and I like Rob Zombie's voice with these
things I gotta say though that I wasn't
in the greatest mood when the film was
done no I didn't like it it's just like
it's such like an experience of just
like mean stuff you're not gonna make
kind of like he's not gonna make you
feel good and I can't blame anybody
that's the thing about most Rob Zombie
movies it's like I can't blame you for
not being into that cuz you don't always
want to come out of the theater feeling
kind of icky yeah but I do appreciate
that that art exists and it does
something for me there are a lot of good
performances in this film to not not
just Richard break but I thought meg
Foster was terrific the the other woman
in the film the older woman I was really
happy that that character got a lot of
time in and she's really terrific in
this and I thought Jeff Daniel Phillips
did a good job as well playing kind of a
realistic guy because you know in Lords
of Salem he was a lot more kind of
you know genuine good likeable and in
this movie he's not a bad guy but there
are times there were moments they had
with him where it's like dude shut up
you're not helping in a very realistic
way so there are little flourishes this
movie has that I think are good I know
some people complain that some of the
cinematography is a little too grimy and
I get that like especially when actual
violent fights are happening like
sometimes the camera is so crazy that it
is hard to see and and I can totally can
see the chainsaw going inside the woman
yeah and it's like I liked the chaos but
I get it his music choices too I think
are always really cool like Rob Zombie's
is one of those directors who can always
pick a neat song and making on scene out
of it that really shows even early on
like The Devil's Rejects with free bird
mm-hm yeah like that's like that's what
I think free bird now I know a lot of
people hate Halloween but I really like
the The Love Hurts montage in that movie
and stuff like that like he's always
using interesting music this is a movie
like we said before I can't blame you
for not liking I know a lot of people
hate it I know some people really love
it it's definitely unique to now what I
would say to summing up is a generic Rob
Zombie but generic Rob Zombie done well
it's still specific but it is like yeah
it's Rob Zombie playing generic film
it's just a generic Rob Zombie yeah it's
like it's a little bit tighter perhaps
than house of 1000 corpses but house of
thousand corpse is a little more crazy
and wild and and she's a little bit more
ambitious with house of 1000 corpses I
feel yeah and there's a lot I'm playing
around between crazy yeah he tries more
on the characters I felt were cuz one
thing I would have liked from this is
for the carnie like the the clown
villains to be a little bit to be a
little bit more distinct to be a little
bit more defined oh I thought they're
distinct you did you have I mean you got
the Nazi little person speaking Spanish
you've got the two like disgusting they
were all pretty much just loud and angry
that okay yeah that's right like that's
all they were yeah yeah the outsides are
unique but that's what I mean on paper
the internal stuff the background that's
where he shows his range it's the
expression of the personalities that I
felt he lacks in range of
you know I don't know if he's like
objective against having a co-writer or
someone taking a look at a second draft
or something because it does seem like
that he that it's all written by him
yeah and that's that isn't for better
for worse thing that I definitely can
feel as a Rob Zombie fan I am curious to
see what would happen if you directed
somebody else's script or a script that
somebody else touched like a jet Apatow
movie you know totally just like a jet
Apetit I'd like a knocked-up sequel
though we all been wanting [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you
yeah okay but yeah it's like I kind of
placed this in between depending on you
kind of in between house and in Devil's
Rejects it's like it's a little more
structurally unified than House of
thousand corpses perhaps but it isn't
perhaps the force of nature this sort of
magic force of nature that The Devil's
Rejects is for playing the hits I still
think it's cool but you know it is
playing the hits I definitely want to
see him do something more interesting
next time but he said it himself he's
been trying to make a few different
movies now and this was the one that
someone was like Wolverine like this
right now I mean I mean it was a cooked
up project and he admitted that like you
just came up with some idea cuz like the
idea of like [ __ ] going wrong and like a
carnival with killer clown like a lot of
people have come up with that as their a
cruel horrible
yeah idea he was just one of the few who
like actually got it done you know yeah
it's unlike most anything you'll see in
the theater this year must you like
anything Rob Zombie makes is unlike
anything else I give it a beep - oh sure
yeah I can get on board with that
get stuck but now maybe I'll give it a B
just cuz I I like his movies more than
you yeah cuz movies like a little more I
saw his films way before he stops I know
you did in fact you helped me get around
Rob Zombie before I even saw the from
I'd heard his music you can be a fan
before you're venomous boobs before you
even saw those you know that's yeah you
know he's I he's got something that does
it for me he scratches a niche for me
the way only he can well it says let's
make some appealing is that there's a
there's an authenticity in his own style
of authenticity yeah
you know and I just like his eye you
know like his eyes his eye I'm sure he's
got a nice size to him oh you mean like
his vision I just like to stare into
pictures of his eyes
what's his sunglasses on his eyes all
right guys if you're new to the channel
subscribe today become rejected by
getting a subscription Sean John is the
social media manager of facebook.com
slash blue Beyonce at facebook.com slash
the real rejects [ __ ] let's give a
shout out to Sheri moon zombie do they
have a kid I don't think don't have a
kid you'll stay a lead actress forever
if you do that I mean hopefully she
could it's proven statistically it's
[ __ ] up than any actress and becomes a
mom does not ever have a career after it
well there's not one actress out there
who has had a baby
and still works on all that is a true
that's a true stick
hey man I'll do my research before I say
[ __ ] in front of the camera totally
always all the time never not Hollywood